hi everyone alex gent here so in today's
video i'm going to be talking about
anti-spins
how they differ from extensions and in
spins
make sure you stick around to the end of
the video because i'll also be showing
the martial application with the kenjo
and saber
okay let's get into it
so to properly understand what an
anti-spin is we first need to have a
look at what an extension and in spit is
if i extend this ball out you can see my
arm and
the chain and ball are all in line and
they're all rotate in the same direction
so in relation to me they're all going
anti-clockwise
if i was to do an in-spin for example
like this
or at the sides you can see that the
ball
is actually spinning the same direction
but it's doing more rotations than it
would
if it was on an extension so that would
be an extension this will just be an
instant
like i say it doesn't matter which point
it's fitting it could just be one spin
for example on top of my head or it
could be at the sides or it could be at
the bottom
the main thing is that it's actually
spinning the same direction
in which my arm is now where that
changes
if we were for example doing something
like this
where i'm spinning inwards if i change
the direction
of where my hands going you can see the
spin of the ball
remains the same in terms of that it's
still spinning
in that anti-clockwise direction whereas
my
arm in relation to me is now going
clockwise
now with the club i can do the same
thing my arm
is moving clockwise and the club is
moving
anticlockwise with the club obviously
you can slow it down
obviously with the ball and chain you
can't hold it out
horizontally but here you can have a
look
the end of it is actually remaining on
the horizontal plate
and the bit where i'm grabbing is
actually moving around
in a circular motion
so then when you put the two together it
looks something like that
now the same could be done on a vertical
plane
now with the staff you're essentially
combining those two movements together
one end is working on the horizontal
plane which is this
end and the other end is working on the
vertical plate so as this goes out to
the side this is going up
and this end is going across on the
horizontal plane
the same movement could be also done
taking this side behind
the head so for example instead of
taking in front i could take it behind
again that movement would look something
like that
but you can see all the principles i've
talked about before
weightlessness and isolations
they all come into play here because
actually an anti-spin
is a type of isolation you can see here
i'm letting the momentum
of the staff do the work in terms of the
weight
as this bounces up and down and also
like i mentioned with the isolations
before i'm getting behind the movement
of there and it's going into this linear
uh motion now i can just switch this
into an anti-spin just by letting the
motion
continue and it kind of forms this um
diamond shape now there's so many
different types of anti-spins that you
can do
and enhancement is just a type of
isolation so how's this all fitted to
martial application
well in a previous video i talk about
isolations and i mentioned the 15th joe
saburi
now this essentially is a type of
isolation it's part of
the quadrant the top quadrant on a
anti-spin but where else does this fit
in
well if i talked about raising the joe
if i raise it in this manner
i'm actually raising in a
in spin as i mentioned earlier
this is an inspin so i'm raising
in an instant weight and then when i'm
putting down
i'm just reversing the direction so i'm
actually cutting down
in a way that you would call an in spin
because it's rotating
the same direction in which my arm is
rotate okay obviously the difference is
we're just working on this one quadrant
so it's raising up
on an in spin cutting down
on an instant now if we want to change
that
and raise it up like this
and cut down
[Applause]
it's now clean it's raising on a
anti-spin
which is like that and then it's joining
up
with the in-spin so it's actually
creating one circle
[Music]
now it's probably easier to relate to
this movement when i do it with the ken
take the first ken saburi
that movement there as i mentioned we've
got the in spin coming up
and then he's been coming down
if for example we switch to
the fifth kensebury
you can have a look that when it comes
round into this position
we're actually using that same idea of
an anti-stone
to take it round
because we're not raising it in a way
where it raises up first
in lane cuts we're actually taking it
around to the side
and it's creating this anti-spin feeling
it's that feeling that it's creating
when it goes to the side
here and then behind the head
and then clean
so it's going from being horizontal
to being down in line with it with your
back
and then it's going into that in spin
motion
when cutting so again looking over the
saber
if you take this movement here it's the
same thing
i'm raising it up and this is kind
it's kind of like it's going into that
anti-spin motion
again just working on this top quadrant
as i raise it up
it's as if it's going into the anti-spin
but then it continues that circle
to cut down in a in spin motion
like we're doing an inspect
so it comes up with an anti-spin cuts
down with an insulin
anyway i hope you found this interesting
and you can relate to this concept
i'll be covering anti-spins in a little
bit more detail in future videos
and as always please like share and
subscribe if you enjoyed the video
and leave a comment down below thanks
again for watching and i'll catch you
again soon